Georgia is facing harsh criticism today
after voters say they encountered major
issues casting ballots in yesterday's
primary lines in some areas stretch for
hours amid reports of voting machine
problems and ballots that just were not
delivered in a statement voting rights
group fair fight blame quote
incompetence and malfeasance at the
state level fair fight founder that
Stacey Abrams is the author of the new
book it's called our time is now power
purpose and the fight for a fair America
Abrams as you know was also the 2018
Democratic nominee for governor in
Georgia she joins us now from Atlanta
boy-oh-boy Stacey did timings seem to
work out in our favor when we booked you
to talk about your book but now we have
to start with what happened in Georgia
yesterday the headline in your paper
says major meltdown and I'm wondering as
you look at this are you thinking I know
this song I know all the words what do
you think when you look at what happened
yesterday
it's exactly what I talked about in our
time is now which is that the ability
for voter suppression to work is almost
complete Georgia has seen this before
yesterday was I think one of the most
egregious examples and I want to be
clear it wasn't simply targeted or
certainly it didn't simply happen in
democratic strongholds it happened
across the state because one of the
problems with voter suppression with the
incompetence and malfeasance that we see
in the Secretary of State's office in
Georgia is that while the target may be
communities of color
maybe voters of color or Democratic
voters it hits everyone the long lines
happened mostly in the urban areas but
we had to see extensions in Democratic
and Republican areas including the
Republican area represented by the
Republican Speaker of the House this is
a complete meltdown and failure of the
Secretary of State's office and that's
what I find so interesting that it was
both Democrats and Republicans who were
complaining some people waited in line
for five hours I saw a lady sitting
there in the rain with her little child
in an umbrella but now the Democrats and
Republicans are both pointing fingers at
each other who's to blame here and why
does it keep happening the blame risk
solely and square
on the shoulders of the Secretary of
State and that's the crux of the lawsuit
that we filed in the wake of the 2018
election the Secretary of State is the
superintendent of elections that means
it's his job to make sure that democracy
works in every County that it shouldn't
matter where you live but the problem
with voter suppression is that in their
urge and zeal to break the machinery for
certain communities they've broken it
for everyone we saw this happen across
the state but we do know that it was in
Union City last night that the last
voter didn't finish until 12:30 6:00
a.m. that happens because voter
suppression is real and because we keep
alighting the notion that we can fix it
we can't wait for justice to come and
that's why clarified action has been
collecting stories and has been filing
lawsuits because until we can change the
people in charge we have to focus on
changing their behavior by bringing
attention to what they do wrong but you
know Stacey even you had a problem I was
reading that you tried to vote absentee
and that didn't work out for you because
clearly there's a problem with the
absentee ballot and now we're five
months away from an election what was
the issue you had and what can be done
to fix it in five months
the issue I had was that my absentee
ballot although I applied for it fairly
early in the process when it finally
arrived the return envelope was sealed
as I pointed out I tried to steam it
open because I watched a lot of Perry
Mason it didn't work and so I had to go
vote in person but the reality is across
the state and around the country
we know that vote by mail is actually a
good thing but what we saw happen in
Georgia had a failure of investment of
resources that's why the heroes Act can
this be fixed a zillion dollars can this
be fixed absolutely can this be kissed
before November before November okay it
absolutely can if the US Senate will
approve the heroes Act and the three
point six billion dollars to fix this
problem not just in Georgia but in
Pennsylvania in Maryland across the
country we simply have to put the
resources in to scale up our are
mechanisms here's the thing to remember
34 states
vote-by-mail with no excuses 16
additional states allowed vote-by-mail
in some form but unless we have
guardrails that hold everyone to the
same standards and the investment that
makes it possible what we saw happen in
Georgia was a failure in estimate a
failure of training and a failure of
direction Stacy I've got less than 30
seconds you know it's widely reported
you're on the short list for a Joe
Biden's VP we talked about it last time
you were here and clearly you're very
interested
have you had recent conversations so
much has changed since the last time you
were here have you had recent
conversations with team Biden I I've
been focused on promoting my book our
time is now because this is a moment to
have a discussion about the country we
want next and that can only happen if we
understand what voter suppression looks
like and we fight for a fair America
across this day the country okay you can
focus on your book and other things we
know you're a good multitasker Stacey
Abrams we thank you I have a feeling
that this won't be the last conversation
we will have for you with you before
this election in November thank you so
much